Speaker 1: Mypillow Mike Lindell,
the CEO and founder of Mypillow,
is yet again saying he is about to blow the
roof off. He's going to blow your socks off
with his latest event, the Election Crimes Summit.
This is so hard to take seriously at this point.
The Springfield News-leader announces my
Mike Pillow Mypillow CEO Mike Lindell,
Mypillow CEO and prominent election fraud
theorist, plans to return to Springfield,
Missouri in August to host an Election Crime
Bureau summit. This will be August 15 and 16.
This is yet another one of these events at which
no election crimes will be revealed. That is my
sense. Here is Mike Pillow with a very difficult
to believe prediction that this will be the most,
most watched show in world history. It's hard
to take it even at all seriously. My friends.
Speaker 2: We've got the Election Crime Bureau.
It's going great. We've got the summer coming
up. We're going to keep pushing out August 16th
and 17th in Springfield, Missouri. It's going to
be the biggest simulcast or the biggest watch
program, I hope, in history, because if you.
Speaker 1: This will be
bigger than the MASH finale.
Speaker 2: We're going to show everybody the
plan going forward. We're going to stay with
all the evidence over the last two years, What
we can do with that, what can we do with that
even order that no judges are looking at it.
Speaker 1: What I love that every judge is
ignoring what we're saying, but what can
we do going beyond that? He's going to
let you know that at this event.
Speaker 2: What can we do? So
that's going to be really important. Yeah, And.
Speaker 1: It's stunning to me that Mike Lindell
is able to say these things with a straight face.
Is he ever going to drop this? I don't know. Now,
you might remember we recently last week
we interviewed Bob Zeidman, Robert Zeidman,
he is the cyber guy who is now owed $5
million by Mike Pillow because Bob Zeidman,
an admitted Trump supporter, voted for Trump
twice proved Mike Pillow's claims. Wrong. Mike
Pillow didn't have evidence of a stolen election
in the United States and that China was involved
in it somehow. And so Pillow now owns owes Bob
Zeidman 5 million bucks. Zeidman The impression
of pillow was that he was serious about all
of these claims. He's a true believer. Here
is Mike Pillow in this same interview on Real
America's Voice, saying that he is not going to
go down quietly. He's going to try to not pay
Bob the 5 million bucks. Take a look at this.
Speaker 2: Everyone heard about.
Speaker 3: The $5 million fiasco.
The challenge there challenging the the
evidence or some of the evidence that I
have and were taken that we talked about with the
lawyers yesterday, we're taking that to court.
Speaker 2: That's that's a report on that.
Speaker 1: There you go. So he's going to be
appealing that. Have you seen a guy who seems
to love losing more than Mike Pillow? He loses
everything he told me. He's lost at months
ago was $35 million related to all of this
election fraud nonsense. He lost 5 million in the
finding with Bob Zeidman. He loses every time he
holds one of these symposia, or as he calls it,
the symposium. Now, it's going to be a summit,
maybe easier to pronounce for him. He he
just loses everything. There's no ratings,
No judges are looking at any losing, losing,
losing. And from all reports and this is said,
I feel bad for the guy for this in the sense that
I feel bad for anybody who starts to, you know,
be alienated from their family because of their.
I guess, insanity. I don't know what else to call
it. He seems to really be struggling personally
as a result of all of this. So he's welcome
to come back on the show any time. It's always
interesting to hear from him. We had a perfectly
cordial conversation last time, but there is
some level on which this is truly very sad.